So, let's look at some of the trends
for magnetic disks over the years. The capacity of
magnetic disks, how much data fits on a single
disk, has actually been improving exponentially at the rate
of about two per one or two years for a while. So things are getting better. We
get more and more data per magnetic disk. The
seek time has consistently been five to ten milliseconds
over a number of years, with very slow
improvement. The only things that really improve the
seek time is if we either make a
faster motor that can still move the head assembly
very precisely, which is very hard to do.
Or if we make the platter smaller so that
we traverse a smaller distance. So there has
been some recent improvement in that we have gone
from five inch diameter disks to three and a half, to more recently two and a
half and even smaller. So there has been some improvement in seek time, mainly
because the disks have shrunk. The speed of rotation for disks
has actually been improving. It went from 5,000 rotations per
minute to 10,000 rotations per minute, and even beyond that.
So that part of the magnetic disk speed has been improving. So this type of
improvement requires improvement in what material is
the platter built out of. Another factor that
has been affecting this is the noise.
Disks that rotate faster, tend to both noisier
and also create a higher a pitch sound,
which is less pleasant for people. And this
type of improvement is also relatively slow. And
the speed of this controllers, and the buses over
which we transfer data has been improving at an
okay rate. So really the controller and the bus
are becoming a smaller and smaller fraction of
the overall disk access time. So the disk access
time is pretty much dominated by the seek time
and to a lesser extent now, the rotational latency.
And now you can see why disks have been lagging in improving their
latency relative to memory and processors. This
is because seek time requires better mechanics,
and rotational latency also requires better materials
and better mechanical properties. Both of which
are not really subject to something like Moore's Law that we get for processors.